[Musique]
yvan et rahel bonjour bon je vous
recevons aujourd'hui pour une chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle singer view où
vous recevons en tant que porte parole
de la chaîne spoutnik france médias
russes qu'est ce qui vous a amené à
travailler pour spoutnik france alors
moi j'ai été journaliste pendant plus
d'une dizaine d'années
j'avais arrêté au profit du documentaire
gens disent pour qui et où
j'ai bossé un peu pour tout le monde
j'ai bossé pas mal pour la croire pour
marianne europe 1 j'étais plusieurs
années europe 1 le nouvel obs peut-être
le nouvel obs un peu alors le nouvel obs
très peu puisque ma mère y avait
travaillé je souhaitais pas
travailler là où avait travaillé ma mère
d'ailleurs dans l'ensemble tout ce que
j'ai fait c'était plutôt sous pseudo
avec un autre nom que celui de ma mère
pourquoi au pseudo mais c'est pas un
pseudo en fait c'est je porte ce nom de
ma mère j'ai fait avec le nom de mon
père pour pas pour pages trop jouer les
fils 2 alors fils de qui fils de
catherine ehrel
qu'était quelques cafés libé et l'obs
essentiellement plutôt sur des
problématiques nationales moi j'étais
intéressé par les problématiques
internationales
ça changerait en fait que on a vite fait
on fait vite le procès d'être à certains
postes parce qu'on est pistonné par un
et les pourquoi pourquoi votre
patrouille s'est dégonflé de venir chez
nous parce qu'il a été très échaudé de
son passage arrêt sur images où il avait
en fait un contradicteur
et qui s'est retrouvé avec un oeil
schneidermann et le chroniqueur qui
organisait le débat contre lui donc il
était seul contre trois
s'y retrouver il s'y retrouver un peu un
peu désarmée et il n'a pas pu placer ses
arguments qui s'est dit les
interventions comme ça c'est pas pour
moi si c'est pour me faire des montées
et démontées mon média ça sert à rien
donc là il a envoyé un professionnel de
la rhétorique et de la dialectique pour
nous alors je suis pas professionnel la
rhétorique de la dialectique je suis
donc j'étais journaliste je connais bien
là je connais bien la presse vous êtes
français ouais je suis une vraie raison
de jets de vraies raisons participé à ce
coup tu niques vous avez un casier
judiciaire non pourquoi ces des raisons
de participer à ce public bas parce que
moi j'étais correspondant au venezuela
j'ai un regard critique sur la presse
depuis toujours
j'étais correspondant au venezuela j'ai
vu j'ai vu ce qu'on pouvait attendre
d'un journaliste sur place c'est souvent
un passe plat et dans l'ensemble
dans le sens que je trouve qu'il ya dans
la presse une une amie une unanimité qui
est dangereuse finalement pour la vérité
c'est qui c'est quoi la vérité à la
vérité en général se situe
en marge de ce qui est écrit dans la
presse donc la presse quand la presse
décide de parler quelque chose de faire
une campagne sur un sur un problème ou
contre quelqu'un il ya toujours des
intérêts derrière toujours toujours
toujours et derrière spoutnik ses coups
les intérêts bas derrière spoutnik c il
ya un double un double intérêt je dirais
c'est d'une part faire entendre le point
de vue
jirel dans un premier temps je dirais le
point de vue de la russie parce que la
russie est présenté par tous comme le
mâle l'ennemi à abattre alors que alors
que c'est un membre permanent du conseil
de sécurité enfin c'est quelqu'un avec
qui les statuts de l'onu prévoyait de
composer bon depuis depuis la chute de
l'urss on compose plus du tout avec avec
ce grand pays c'est une grande puissance
et il est important que son point de vue
soit au minimum connu on dit pas qui
skie t-il eu son point de vue de na pas
à s'imposer aux autres réalités mais il
faut au moins entendre ce qu'ils ont à
dire combien ça gagne le porte parole
chez spoutnik
pas énormes ce un pas énorme et on sagan
mieux ça gagne je pense que en tout cas
pour un journaliste débutant azpitik je
pense que ça gagne les conditions sont
meilleures a conduit un journaliste
débutant chez spotify là combien il en
porte parole lisa combien
je dirais qu'un
journaliste débutant est
doit être à
à 2 smic et un porte parole pareil 2002
voilà
un peu plus vos sources de revenus votre
business model chez spoutnik vous
recevez 100% de votre argent de moscou
est ce que vous avez des revenus
publicitaires est ce que vous touchez
les subventionnant on est est ce que
vous avez une carte de presse alors
certains des cartes de presse pas tous
on est aussi on a un système aussi ou où
il y à il ya deux statues des
journalistes et des producteurs les
producteurs étant
censé aider les journalistes à
à trouver des interlocuteurs
ce qui n'est pas toujours évident
moi j'ai un peu l'impression que tout le
monde fait plus ou moins un boulot de
journaliste maintenant quand on voit ce
que la carte de presse enfin un qui la
carte de presse est accordée à qui ne
l'est pas je pense que toute façon là
dedans il ya il ya quand même un
problème qui est peut-être plus lié
d'ailleurs
réduction d'impôt failli à moi je
connais des ddd des gens qui ont la
carte de presse alors qu'ils font du
casting pour des boîtes de prod il ya
d'autres gens qui font un boulot
formidable de journalistes qui n'ont pas
les 50 % de revenus
avec des fiches de paye écrite
journaliste émanant de deux d'organes de
presse reconnu par la commission qui
mérite largement la carte de presse et
qu'ils n'ont pas
le business model du spoutnik le
business model de spoutnik c'est un
média public qui est payé à 100% par le
ministère la culture
russe qui est international je dirais
que c'est le même que rfi ou
france 24 ou
ou des médias comme ça on parle pas de
la fp parce que l' afp la spa dans ses
statuts l'interdiction d'être financés
par part par le gouvernement bon alors
pour compenser ça il ya 40% je crois ou
quelque chose comme ça des revenus
alors c'est 40 % je rajoute quand même
je crois mais qui sont des abonnements
de d'entités publiques plus ou moins
bidons c'est à dire qu'il ya tout un tas
de gens qui sont abonnés à l afp qui
n'en n'ont aucun usage et c'est une
subvention déguisée parce que vous
connaissez la charte de munich la charte
de munich non c'est compliqué
charte de munich les droits et devoirs
du journalisme
ça a été décidée à munich en quelle
année
c'est aux alentours de 70 je crois non
voilà
donc vos votes fonds de roulement chez
spotnicks et combien
alors
il semblerait qu'on soit en en
légèrement en dessous de 100 millions de
dollars aux parents pour spoutnik france
n'annonce pratiquement de spoutnik
monique france il touche combien aucune
idée
du tout du tout vous savez combien de
salariés
plus d'une dizaine
plus d'une dizaine ouais tous français
où tous russes ils tous français à
l'exception de
deux 2 2 2 2 dont le rédac'chef donc il
ya deux russes est tous français ouais
le deuxième russe ce qui la deuxième
russe se bat elle et
elle
était journaliste
elle est journaliste est là elle repart
à moscou donc en fait comment il
s'appelle xénia look rihanna va bien
elle a quelques annonces boutique elle
était journaliste au même titre que les
autres maintenant elle va elle va plus
se va plus se concentrer sur le site
internet qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
répondre aux journalistes français qui
vous jette l'opprobre
dont j'ai un truc qui sifflent pendant
qu est ce que vous pouvez répondre aux
journalistes qui répondent ou qui vous
jette l'opprobe en vous disant que vous
êtes la voix du fsb la voix de la
propagande russe et que vous êtes
vecteur de fake news alors et prendre un
par un
d'abord être la voix de quelques est-ce
qu'on est la voix de celui qui nous
finance est ce que on est la voix de
dassault est ce qu'on est la voix de
bouygues est ce qu'on est la voie de
free
ce qu'on voit là les médias français
sont à 90 % financés par des grands
industriels
qui viennent des télécoms de l'armement
du bâtiment
de la banque quant à voir ces gens là
avec la presse si ce n'est le désir de
la contrôler ça c'est une première chose
dont je leur dirai de regarder du côté
de leur financement à eux et du travail
qu'ils font eux mêmes sur les
malversations éventuelle de ces grandes
sociétés
le fsb
en arrivant au spoutnik je me disais
c'est super on va avoir des super
informations première main
rendez-vous direct avec les services
donc le fsb n'en communique très peu
très très mal est en tout cas bien moins
que les renseignements français qui
balancent à droite à gauche des infos
qui l'arrangent
fsb c'est pas ça ray des sources pour
les services français dans quelques
heures il balancera des infos
attendant tous les canards
quand certains le monde le canard
enchaîné il tousse 10 selon des sources
de renseignement selon des sources
proches du renseignement selon voilà ça
c'est pas le fait pas trop futée de
chaussures vous en rien du tout rien du
tout et c'est enfin c'est leur façon de
communiquer sais je j'en suis presque
est ce que vous sentez
l'administration russe présente dans vos
looks ou est ce qu'il ya dans la main
est ce que l'oeil de mouscou veille sur
vous non je n'en est totalement
dépendant si vous voulez traiter un
sujet sur poutine vladimir poutine ou
sur la corruption qui peut y avoir en
russie où sur l'état des prisons sur des
choses comme ça moi je pense qu'il se
passe un peu à l'état des prisons je
revendais là dessus parce que l'état des
prisons en france est déplorable c'est
un des pires au monde donc on n'avoue
jamais ce qu'ils disent que je me laisse
comparer aux dangers de la cloche grave
jamais ce qu'on part au dernier de la
classe et en l'occurrence la france est
un des derniers de la classe donc on
peut on pourra voir comment ça se passe
en russie et en france on est vraiment
très très mauvais là dessus il ya pas
encore de raquette on devra quête de
racket sur les détenus ah bon comment
avant en france il est des raquettes sur
les détenus évidemment enfin il ya tout
ce qui a tout ce qu'il faut pas qu'il se
passe dans une prison ça se passe en
france un accord
faut voir avec faut voir avec les gens
de l'oip 1 qui sont plus spécialistes
mais l'oip qui veut dire l'observatoire
international des prisons 1 qu'est la
gentillesse de nous parler de temps en
temps ça on en parlera d'ailleurs de nos
sources des gens qui acceptent et qui
accepte pas un combat on verra si on en
parle la question se profile ça marche
donc est ce que l'oeil de moscou veille
sur vous est ce que vous avez non moi je
pense que je pense qu'il ya une question
je pense qu'il ya raymond brusque
lentilles haché nuit
la même tendance la même tendance qui a
chez journalistes français sont sur
facebook ni qu'il ya une autre censure
je pense qu'il ya eu une autocensure
qui est aussi liée à la jeunesse du
média ça fait deux ans qu'on existe
il ya des gens qui sont motivés qui
arrivent avec des envie de bien faire de
faire bouger les choses de donner un
point de vue alternatif du coup ils
seront ils se concentrent sur il se
concentre sur les sur les gens cons
quand le plus souvent la parole et je
veux dire il n'y a pas besoin de
spoutnik pour pour donner des infos sur
vraies ou fausses sur ce qui peut se
passer en russie avec l'opposition
avec plaisir avec eux la liberté de la
presse
voilà la liberté de la presse
elle existe partout elle est manipulée
par tout ça elle est partout et nulle
part c'est ça ça est le pire ennemi
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le pire ennemi
du journaliste c'est l'autocensure qui
très forte très très forte l'autocensure
et le conformisme
je veux dire dans la devise de spoutnik
sais c'est quoi c'est
telling the untold donc on dévoile ce
que les autres ce dont les autres ne
parle pas vous avez des bleus des volets
quoi par rapport aux autres déjà être
déjà si lille c'est toute la presse
contre vous ou je suis un peu un peu
d'aidé enfin qu'on voit sur des
problématiques comme qui nous intéresse
on est quand même très orienté sur la
presse internationale fin sur de la
géopolitique
les pages internationales
des différents journaux
quand on voit l'unanimité avec laquelle
sont traités des sujets comme
l'ukraine ou la syrie on se dit qu'il ya
un loup
sju parce que vous êtes journaliste ou
c'est l'oeil de moscou qui vous dit
qu'il joue
en ce qui concerne
d'abord parce que je suis journaliste et
que je sais que je sais que quand il ya
quand tout le monde est d'accord c'est
qu'il ya un problème
d'autre part concernant l'ukraine c'est
parce que j'y suis allé de nombreuses
fois où ça bat kiev kharkov comme on dit
les salles du crayon je sais pas je sais
pas j'y suis allé avec un fixeur avec
plusieurs fixeur
du côté ukrainien du côté russe les deux
les deux c'était compliqué de travailler
du côté ukrainien pas du tout pas du
tout pas du tout il ya longtemps que
médias russes à moi j'étais pas en tant
que médias russes j'étais pas en tant
que média russe jeu d'un film
qui s'appelait qui s'appelait
poutine pour toujours ta un film
violemment critiques de poutine
qui a été taxé de
propagande occidentale
anti-poutine aveugle et c
est cela dit
j'étais j'étais vraiment étonné du
pouvoir des milices travis hector
deux groupes au gré de ce moment là en
ukraine
price hector donc ouais
j'accompagnais il avait pas du tout de
ce qu'ils faisaient moi ils m'ont très
gentiment amiens en ratonnades c'est un
des moments les plus gênants de ma
carrière de journaliste
je leur demandais mais qu'est ce que
vous faites le soir et disent ah ben on
cherche on cherche des gens avec des
drapeaux communistes ou du drapeau russe
ont fait des ont fait des rondes alors j
en émoi en ronde mais qui me font monter
dans leur voiture avec la caméra est bon
finalement ils n'ont pas trouvé de
communistes dont qui sont allés se
rabattre sur les squats des clandestins
d'asie centrale ils arrivent ils cassent
les bouteilles et il est content
contrôle d identité
et moi autant son analyse c'est la
première fois que je me fait gerber un
peu parce que j'ai rien fait mais en
même temps voilà j'avais je l'avais
javel et je les avais la main dans le
sac mais ils s'en foutent ils s'en
foutent ils sont ils sont contents de ce
qu'ils font ils sont contents de ce
qu'ils font et tout le monde sait ce
qu'ils font tout le monde sait ce qu'ils
font quand quand paul moreira a sorti
son film hyper soft sur
le réel pouvoir de l'extrême droite en
ukraine et des deux et deux de ces gens
qui ont qui ont sauvé la qu'il ya eu des
ministères est ce que c'est pour ça un
secours tentent de vous engager
je crois va
je crois enfin parce que j'avais un
tropisme sur sur la russie en ce moment
j'en ai vu d'autres et parce que
et parce que j'étais journaliste et
parce que j'avais un discours parce que
j'avais un discours sur le discours de
la presse je te dire comment rafa a
sorti son son documentaire sur l'ukraine
il ya toute la presse qui lui est tombé
dessus et je sais plus combien 30 ou 50
correspondants
correspondant qui avait bossé sur
l'ukraine qui ont qui lui ont fait une
lettre ouverte
insultante pour dire qu'il avait rien
compris à l'ukraine et qu' il avait
manipulé l'information alors qu'il
n'avait fait que relater ce qu'il avait
vu et il n'avait pas vu grand chose un
point ce qui peut se passer
mais d'autres vu exactement l inverse
d'autres ont vu que travis hector
n'exerce pas le rôle de police en
ukraine parce que c'est facile de le
voir voilà bah il ya des gens qui l'ont
vu qu'ils n'ont pas dit lequel tous les
autres comme ils s'appellent raf s'est
fait non bah oui comment il s'appelle
basse qu'il fallait oublier piotr
quelque chose est en tout cas le mec le
mec du monde qui maintenant est à
jérusalem
voilà cette promotion après avoir fait
son boulot sur l'ukraine il a fait ça
parce que vous avez déjà traité des
sujets contre eux poutine chez spoutnik
directement directement je crois pas je
crois que ça va je crois que ça va
devenir possible ça va devenir possible
salle pour l'instant pour l'instant il
n'y a peut-être pas ouais ben hassine
bien sûr qu'il y en a bien sûr qu'on a
bien sûr canam est temps que
je dire tant que
les milliards focalise sur une
opposition qui touchent des gens qui
parlent de russie
ce sont des gens issus en france 1 sont
des gens issus au soutien d'une
opposition qui représente 4 à 5% de la
deûle à
l'électorat russe trois qualités trois
défauts de la russie
trois qualités et 3 défaut de la russie
alors
trois jeux commencer par les défauts
ils sont
entiers dans le sens où ils chercheront
ils chercheront pas la nuance forcément
un autre défaut
un autre défaut ils croient pas
à
la démocratie occidentale comme modèle
universel applicable partout
et un autre défaut je dirais ça s'est un
peu personnel je pense qu'ils sont
sans heurts religieux
en qualité
en qualité ils se battent pour une cause
juste
qui est le
pluralisme à la fois de l'information de
l'exercice du pouvoir et
et
du partage des richesses et des zones
d'influencé
en notre qualité
ils ont rien dit quand ils se sont fait
piquer la victoire de la seconde guerre
mondiale
parce qu'ils l'ont dit le problème c'est
qu'ils ont communiqué beaucoup à
l'intérieur mais à l'extérieur on a fini
par être convaincu que c'était les
américains qui avaient gagné la seconde
guerre mondiale depuis combien de temps
vous travaillez chez eux six mois
pour sais que ça va durer je sais pas
vous avez un cdd ou un cdi
un cdd fou de salaire est versé en
france ou en russie franche
mais oui non mais cette histoire de
seconde guerre mondiale c'est marrant
parce que
ils vous ont bombardé porte parole d'acs
ou même temps quand je suis arrivé et
que maintenant six mois six mois
la seconde guerre mondiale ça
t'intéresse pas on le connaît bien le
sujet d'accord bon ben tant pis bon
maintenant l'avenir de ce public alors
l'avenir de spoutnik moi ça m'intéresse
vachement parce que
bon on ne nous aime pas on a fait notre
petit effet
ça y est là commencent à s'intéresser à
nous on commence à nous scrutent et
je pense que il faut qu'on soit plus
nombreux il faut qu'on recrute
qu'on ait tant de notre réseau radio à
des zones francophones
qu'on n'avait pas prévu on a une grosse
audience au fric et on a une grosse
audience en afrique du nord et en
afrique subsaharienne je pense que c'est
des choses qu'on peut qu'on peut
développer parce que
hors de france dans la zone francophone
les gens pas du tout du tout le même
point de vue on va au maroc le problème
la syrie il est traité mais complètement
différemment
voilà ils veulent pas des djihadistes
qui considère l'opposition comme jill
scott voilà c'est clair et net pour donc
on a donc on va je voudrais qu'on se
développe par là bas je voudrais aussi
qu'on est un peu plus de temps pour se
libérer du flux de l'info au profit des
profits au profit d' enquête et du
budget pour faire des enquêtes bas en
éventuellement on pourra avoir des
budgets sont bien combien touche footing
france déjà en
je sais pas mais
c'est le budget qui elle sur toutes les
antennes de spoutnik
me semble
accessible accessible enfin en tout cas
je pense qu'on aurait les moyens on
aurait voulu qu'on retrouve ou dans le
xviie côte que j'ai cru lire un papier
contre vous comme quoi c'était très
difficile de vous joindre on a mis sept
minutes vous joindre mais c'est non mais
on voit quand même le rédacteur en chef
mais ben ouais m'enfin vous l'avez juin
et vous avez mis sept minutes à nous
rejoindre mais en même temps on va pas
leur jeter la pierre je veux dire cédé
19 ans ils sont 19 ans les gens confejes
et le papier je pense que c'est le cas
des biens qu'ils ont ils ont ils ont
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ruchers
today
le grand frère de spoutnik est ce que
c'est le don juan c'est une télé ils
remplissent en où on est
une agence internationale multimédia
sert qu'on est très web
un peu vidéo et et radio et donc la
radio la radio nous prend beaucoup de
temps votre audience c'est quoi notre
audience c'est 25 35
chiffres
la proportion on doit être à la main à
60 on peut être à 70 % en dessous de 35
ans
25 35 30 55 ouais c'est ça va
ou jeune femme une femme beaucoup
beaucoup de femmes aussi utiliser des
utilitaires pour sonder un peu votre
communauté va pas assez moi j'ai faim on
est on est on fait nous analyse google
analytics j'ai commandé un rapport passe
mais bon il faut l'attendre
je suis assez je suis assez fasciné par
tout ça parce que c'est assez nouveau
c'est intéressant c'est plutôt des gens
éduqués c'est aussi des gens qui lisent
le reste de la presse et qui viennent et
qui viennent sur spotnicks chercher lire
des infos qu'ils ont pas ou ou une autre
vision des maîtres des mêmes questions
ce que je trouve assez intéressant comme
démarche et je regrette que en fait les
journalistes fassent pas la même quoi
quand vous vous retrouvez à traiter des
sujets un peu complexes ont cliqué et
aride où
votre rédaction vous laisse le plus
grand de l'attitude ou pas ouais ouais
on ne t'en prends pas vraiment de risque
on
fait comme tout le monde on cherche des
recherches de spécialistes chargés
spécialiste des implants ça se passe les
salles de rédaction chez spoutnik
ou des ans réunis le matin on dit tel
était le sujet donc on a un nombre
limité de 2 journalistes donc on dit on
décide de trois sujets général
deux ou trois commentaires ce qu'on
appelle commentaires qui sont des
interviews et
cinq ou six brève
en fait ce qui sert ce qui ce qui sert
de ski axe un peu notre travail c'est
celle émission radio donc veut et qui
ont des missions radio vous allez
cliquer ou mais d'émissions radio
combien de bain on a tous les jours tous
les jours
de 17 à 19 heures sur la fréquence de
radio aligre pour l'instant
bientôt donc en ile-de-france seulement
bientôt dans d'autres régions de france
et peut-être à l'étranger plus tard donc
c'est une émission de deux heures deux
heures de contenus exclusifs
qui est
compose donc qui composait pour une demi
heure d'un show de soi rachel martin
soit jacques sapir plus une heure et
demie c'est à dire trois journaux en
fait
de sons qui sont présentés pas qu'ils
soient qui sont le travail de la
rédaction et qui sont présentées par
edouard chanot et marie-claire ville que
vous vous êtes jugés pour vous couvrir
français doute
d'autres journaux d'autres pays
bas je pense que pour l'instant
pour l'instant on est mené on est jugé
on est jugé comme comme propagande
je pense juste titre ou pas non
ils devraient nous juger en tant que
point de vue alternatif
voilà il ya d'autres points de vue qui
existe il n'ya pas une vérité je pense
que ça vaut le coup de se renseigner sur
sur les points de vue des autres plutôt
que de croire que parce qu'on travaille
au monde on incarne la vérité ce que
c'est faux c'est faux le monde ment
comme tout le monde pourquoi pourquoi le
mouvement
pourquoi le monde ment parce que
pourquoi vous n'avez témoin que le monde
parce que parce que le monde c'est la
référence absolue de la presse française
référence absolue jeu quand
quand libé sur un scoop ça n'est pas un
scoop tant que c'est pas repris par le
monde et quand le monde le sort il se
gêne pas pour dire c'est un scoop c'est
nous qui l'avons sorti et est à vous
maintenant de reprendre de reprendre nos
infos ce que les gens font les
journalistes les journalistes la
première source des journalistes les
autres journalistes dont qui bosse entre
sur sur le même sujet les mêmes infos
les mêmes sources quelles sont vos
sources à vous chez spoutnik on a ça
d'abord et ensuite on a on a un chouette
réseau on a un chouette réseau
international donc il ya tout les toutes
les autres éditions de foot ni qui nous
envoient des trucs des infos des
interviews des commentaires qui sont
traduits alors là il ya un service il ya
un truc de traduction qui fait qu on a
une interview en farsi qui qui va être
traduite en russe envoyé à toutes les
rédactions et re traduite en français ou
en espagnol
avec parfois des pièces qui gère ce que
jenson traduction ça se passe à ossen au
siège à moscou
vous avez déjà visité les locaux du
siège non pas encore mais je pense que
je vais aller
je pense que je vais y aller c'est à
s'effacer c'est une grosse machine est
ce que je publie qui a déjà sorti comme
scoop comme ce couple là on a on a sorti
un truc là tout récemment sur ryanair
qui qui touchent des subventions
maquiller via une association
pour la promotion de montpellier
qui qui facturent 700000 euros par an un
site internet bidon
et qui qui envoie 80 % de ses fonds dans
un paradis fiscal donc ils nous ont
écrit en disant c'est pas vrai on touche
pas de subventions illégales on a
évidemment publié lors leurs
commentaires et on l'a on va en rajouter
une couche sur les condamnations qu'ils
ont reçue partout en europe pour des
subventions illégales ça j'aimerais bien
qu'on s'oriente dernier sa pièce qui a
enquêté sur cette affaire
gal nicole combien de temps deux mois
les enquêtes ça fonctionne
les enquêtes ça fonctionne souvent
pareil il ya une info au départ il vient
d'une source
plus ou moins bien intentionnés et qui
ensuite faut vérifier recouper
récupérer les documents qu'il ya
plusieurs styles enquête il ya des
enquêtes comme ça qu'ils viennent d'une
source et ensuite il y'a plus qu'à
vérifier il y a les enquêtes laborieuse
où on cherche on cherche on cherche et
on finit par trouver et toute façon
toute façon quand on compile un certain
nombre d'informations on a souvent un
résumé intéressant avec des des infos
qu'on savait pas à l'ailé
je dire c'est que c'est comme c'est
comme l'espionnage industriel
l'espionnage industriel c'est 80%
d'informations qui sont dans le domaine
public
90 90 %
voilà un qui % d'information se levait
pavé vous ce sont les mots de philippe
qui a duck qui le directeur de ladite
voilà
voilà c'est ça il suffit de compiler des
choses qui sont dans le domaine public
ensuite de trouver la personne qui te
donnera les 10% supplémentaires et tu
arrives avec un truc plus ou moins
saignant
qu'en votre rédacteur au chef se fait
étriller mais il se retrouve
pris entre tenaille avec
daniel schneidermann et deux autres
acolytes
il fallait refroidi beaucoup pas
beaucoup ouais ça l'a refroidi pas mal
parce que
parce qu'en face il y avait nicolas
hénin sur qui il avait quelques quelques
vicois et que nicolas hénin qui était un
personnage
très respecté autant que très
très très bizarre
voilà très décriée mais pas trop en
public et voilà et il intervient
désormais comme un des grands
spécialistes de la russie après avoir
été spécialistes
des jihadistes
il parle ni les russes ni l'arabe c'est
à dire qu'il n'a d'information il n'a
jamais la formation en version originale
ou par les russes n'ont ni l'arabe
koulou tam comment could luta même nom
je parle pas
et donc on le verra plus feutrée dax
chef
parce que la rencontrer ouais ouais ça
déçu on est très déçu mais était très
content de vous était très content de
vous voir
il ay la ilaha illa il a vraiment hésité
et puis en plus bas
donc il était vachement content d'eux
des discussions que vous avez pu avoir
en même temps tu as pas caché que
vous étiez méchant vous allez dur lequel
il tint déjà les autres ils ont dit
inquiète pas on va être équilibré il
nous a semblé boîte et autant vous
annoncer la couleur vous allez d'urnes
ici
on représente notre communauté c'est
très bien notre communauté à des
questions notre communauté nous dit est
ce que vous faites ou des expos knicks
ont l'oeil de moscou en france pour me
sortir de la propagande vous sortir de
la propagande pour vous y mettre c'est
pareil nous sortir nous servir de la
propagande russe non pour vous en sortir
donc pour vous en sortir parce que tirer
dans la propagande vous êtes dans la
propagande anglo saxon et russie à tous
dès que je ne connais pas par ailleurs
donc c'est une technique de comprendre
contre-propagande russe spoutnik et
france24 pas à prendre alors
france 24 france 24 c'est de la
propagande française surtout à
destination de l'afrique puisqu'il ya
plus de l'atelier du pouvoir c'est une
guerre de propagande journalistique à
travers ses médias là où je pense c'est
un véritable question en fait oui voilà
c'est ça c'est ça la vraie la vraie
question c'est est ce que est ce que
plusieurs points de vue sont autorisés
dans le monde mais a pas seulement donc
là la france a perdu a perdu sa guerre
de la deux de la formation france 24 à
une audience
c'est quoi le petit surnom de la lfp
voilà il faut le dire
si si si c'est quoi le petit surnom de
la fp un jour se trouvent trois grandes
agences france propagande bah voilà mais
cela dit ces agences propagande tout
court parce que la fp
elle note française que le siège à bourg
st
le point de vue français à
l'international
ne se distingue plus de reuters ap
comment on fait pour voir le patron de
ton patron on voit le patron mon patron
faucon a été faux qu'on ait tapé ou à la
porte du kremlin où il faut qu'on allait
taper à la porte d'une agence de presse
russe l'onda
ça c'est vraiment la question qui
remonte à chaque fois ouais qui est le
patron de mon parti est derrière
spoutnik c'est à dire que derrière ce
côté qu'il ya une volonté non mais il ya
une volonté d'être clair ouais il ya une
volonté étatique de
de faire parler le point de vue russe
sur le web voilà à ccc du ces du soft
power
c'est assumer ouais oui c'est assumer
que c'est plus à saluer d'autant que
d'autant que la presse et est sans
limite quand il s'agit de la russie sans
limite aucune boisson limite sans limite
c'est à dire que ça va de
la simple
de la simple calomnie horus bashing et
au footing bashing quoi alors donc dès
que
dès que dès qu'on ajoute russe à la fin
d'un mot ça fait ça fait fsb dictature
sanglant monstrueux tout ce qu'on veut
c'est un peu comme de south park avec le
canada ouais ouais c'est ça le blème
canada est moche c'est ça ma rue chanzy
dit il ya le hashtag #civsocial ddte
al-arich on dit gg sa peur de trop à des
russes sur internet search and did it ça
fait marrer tout le monde là est ça fait
marrer tout le monde rêve c est celle je
pense que c'est parti d'un vrai truc
mais que fait il que c'est sa virée à la
blague ça virait à la blague mais c'est
une blague qui est représentatif de 2 de
ce qu'on dit dans la presse on sait c
est russe voilà il ya un bombardement et
quelque part c'est les russes alors que
alors qu'ils sont tous blonds les russes
bah non je pense pas aucun offert aucune
grande puissance aucune grande puissance
nenê toute blanche mais on fait pour
savoir s'ils sont tous blancs où ils
sont tous noirs à quel saint python est
ce que l'opinion publique pesant mais ce
que quelqu'un peut croire que n'importe
quelle grande puissance puisse être tout
blanc ou tout noir moi je crois pas un
mot je lis la presse depuis suffisamment
longtemps pour savoir que chacun défend
ses intérêts ou qu'ils soient évidemment
que évidemment que
l'intervention en syrie est liée à des
intérêts parce pas seulement au fait de
pas ne pas laisser sombrer ce pays dans
le chaos comme comme tous ces pays où
les états unis ont cherché à imposer la
amener la démocratie je parle de
l'afghanistan l'irak la libye qui sont
qui ont fait un bond en arrière enfin
l'afghanistan ça jamais été
se met de la modernité mais la libye la
libye et l'irak avaient des régimes
dictatoriaux
mais d'une part les populations étaient
bien plus en sécurité qu'elles ne le
sont aujourd'hui l'état fonctionner
voilà aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ces deux
pays je connais bien l'irak c'est ces
deux pays qui qui qui vivent mal quoi
j'ai eu mal donc si c'était pour faire
péter la syrie de la même manière je
crois pas que c'était l'intérêt des
syriens je presse russe le cal vous la
lisez maintenant je lis pas le russe
ilia
il ya plusieurs types de presse russe
d'après ce que ce que je sais je sors de
mes connaissances brut en a je
sais des discussions que j'ai avec avec
dimitri ou avec d'autres
il y a
il ya de la presse
d'état ou ou de la presse
privée
favorable pro-gouvernemental quand on
pourrait dire et
la presse privée tout à fait libres et
de la presse privée d'opposition
voilà et ils compris les y compris des
chaînes télé il ya une chaîne télé
indépendante qui qui est qualifié en
russie d'opposition qui a été récemment
interdite en ukraine parce qu'elle était
considérée comme trop riche donc
donc à la presse la bio russie
je passe je n'en sais rien je ne sais
pas si la presse va bien je sais qu'elle
existe qu'il ya un vrai lectorat
est ce que la presse va bien en france
on pourrait poser la même question une
dans une société où on est complètement
sûr informés
voilà la presse se vendent moins en
moins quoi vos chiffres de progression
c'est quoi en un an on a doublé on est
dans l'audience ouais on à doubler
l'audience soit on à doubler l'audience
on est
autour de pas loin de 200 mille bus par
jour
[Musique]
on augmente on a vraiment des vraiment
une grosse audience à gagner autant d
autant des gens qui seront
qu'ils seront convaincus que d'autres
gens qui qui se servent de nous comme
comme presse de complément parce que les
services de renseignement français vous
ont à l'oeil
non enfin qu'est-ce que je sais pas je
sais pas j'imagine parce que quand on
regarde quand on regarde ce fameux
scandale sur le les hackers russes et le
piratage des élections américaines
quand on lit le rapport qui est
finalement publié
niveau hacking ya rien grosso modo le
piratage c'est riche à tous des scouts
nick qui qui ont mené une campagne
d'information c'est d'un fort beau chat
noir
informations ouais bah
c'est pas moi je trouve que c'est plus
un combat un combat de journalistes
qu'un combat d'état et à ce que c'est du
social engineering
d'état et du social engineering qui peut
me rappeler la définition de
l'ingénierie sociale c'est-à-dire
formater le point de vue de la plèbe à
travers des médias ou des influenceurs
ou des techniques comme la structure
fine sur internet
je suis beaucoup moins au point
que toi sur c'est sur ce vocabulaire
maintenant formater le point de vue des
masses
non nous en tout cas on essaye plutôt de
donner une grille de lecture on sait que
l'on sait que on sait qu'on est pour
l'instant une presse de complément
et qu'il est important que les lecteurs
de libé de l'ops le figaro du monde
sache que d'autres choses d'autres
points de vue existent sur les mêmes
problématiques et que d'autres
informations qui méritent d'être connues
arrivent en même temps elle sans qu on
en parle nécessairement nécessairement
dans le pluralité de l'information et la
pluralité de l'information
quand on regarde les commentaires de vos
articles sur les réseaux sociaux on est
ce que vous faites de la modération
apprennent la modération c'est que c'est
un vrai boulot et qu'on est un peu en
sous-effectif donc vous en faites vous
en faites pas il y en a un peu à chaque
fois moi je diminue c'est pas possible
on peut pas laisser ça qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez pas laisser
des insultes
des insultes est-ce que vous pensez que
votre public est principalement
constituée de joe torre dos d'extrême
droite non je pense qu'il y en a je
pense qu'il y en a mais c'est rigolo
parce qu'on les voit souvent par exemple
sur les commentaires s'affronter entre
banlieues rebeu et l'extrême droite
on voit et et pas toujours en n'étant
pas toujours l'un contre l'autre quoi
des fois les deux contre un autre et on
voit un mec qui est clairement qui est
clairement
soient algériens soient marocains soit
soit de banlieue avec avec un autre qui
est clairement ou qui portent un pseudo
typique de france u16 voilà saint
françois d'assise ou typique typique
fachosphère qui va c'est quoi la
fachosphère alors la fachosphère c'est
l'ensemble des
des sites internet et des des mecs qui
sont l'extrême droite qui sont qu'ils
sont
qui sont mobilisés qui montrent leur
présence ou leur désaccord sur
sur des articles ou sur ou qui publient
leurs propres articles ou cdd dessins
sur internet chose faire à côté de ça
hoyé une gauchosphère je pense qu'elle
est
je pense qu'elle est moins active j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est moins active
mais elle existe aussi forcément elle et
elle est également présente sur notre
site les deux fin des deux se répondent
donc sur les problèmes sur le sol et sur
les questions nationales
ils sont souvent pas d'accord sur les
questions internationales ils sont
parfois d'accord je pense qu'il ya pas
vraiment de
règle quel est votre plus vos plus beaux
succès est votre plus beau plantage
facebook inc un tube au succès c'est
d'avoir publié les extraits manquant de
l'interview de vladimir poutine sur tf1
il avait caché tout fin j'avais coupé au
montage tout un tas de trucs sur la
politique internationale
l'importance d'un monde multipolaire qui
avait été coupé déjà publié
est votre plus gros ratage
plus gros ratage j'étais pas là
mais c'est
au tout début de soutenir sur tout nick
a commencé en février et en mars il y
avait cet avion de la lufthansa qui
s'écrasait dans les alpes avec le pilote
qui qui s'étaient enfermés dans la
cabine et qui s'était suicidé en se
jetant contre une montagne quoi est il
ya une
une journaliste qui n'était qui n'était
pas permanente chez nous mais qui avait
un blog ouvert à l'intérieur du site de
spoutnik qui avait dit que c'était la
cia
qui avait fait écraser s'est passé et
s'est passé parce qu'elle publier
directement s'est passé c'est resté
c'est de rester très peu de temps sur le
site donc c'est votre rédac chef qui
s'occupe de toutes les discriminations
des news à sortir et vous avez un board
quelque chose d journaliste référent
pour faire votre client tariel de la
journée où c'est manon se réunit ce
matin et il faudrait en fait la ligne
vous avez des connexions avec les autres
salles de rédaction de ce petit monde on
essaye on a je crois qu'on a un peu les
mêmes problématiques
d'être pressé d'avoir d'avoir une
émission radio à gérer du matin pour le
soir donc on on communique pas autant
que moi je le voudrais pas ce qu'on a
faim c'est un formidable réseau je veux
dire c'est comme
d'avoir d'avoir des bureaux partout dans
le monde on a envie de dire à l'eau
qu'est ce que tu penses de sac est ce
que on et moi même donc ça se développe
ça se développe c'est pas encore tout à
fait suffisant mais
mais mais on y arrive à mieux
communiquer entre d'un bureau à l'autre
ce que vous pensez que vous êtes
transparent avec votre public
transparent avec notre public
je cherche je cherche ce que tu veux
dire par là en fait est ce qu'on dit est
ce qu'on dirait mais nous nous on est un
peu un cas particulier c'est à dire que
quand on veut quelqu'un on va le
chercher au cuir chevelu démarquer en
général on prend pas des petits talons
pour venir taper à la porte donc pour
nous vous rentrez dans le cadre de la
transparence c'est-à-dire que quand on a
besoin de vous parler il ya quelqu'un
pour nous répondent et à quelqu'un pour
venir nous parler donc là le rédacteur
en chef
a été pris par d'autres impératifs elle
m'a envoyé nous a envoyé son porte
parole donc il ya quand même un dialogue
qui s'effectue c'est correct mais est-ce
que vos lecteurs vous demande plus de
transparence par rapport à tous les
quolibets ou les réprimandes ou les
remarques que la presse française peut
vous faire en tant que
service de soupe de moscou une chose
comme ça se faisait pris aux consignes à
sa défaite tout nouveau ars uniquement
pour ça parce que deux communautés de
mise et aller voir spoutnik aller voir
au château des parce que on trouve
qu'ils sont pas très transparent donc il
n'y a été alors aux parents comment vous
faites pour les financer à 100 %
c'est à dire voilà bah c'est au delà de
ça la presse que vos lecteurs vous
demande plus de transparence sur comment
vous construisez l'information comme on
vous trouve salle de rédaction
fonctionne non qu'ils aient le dernier
mot ou des choses comme ça
non non non non on n'a pas reçu ce genre
de demande vraiment où on vous le
demande à être plus transparent la
demande à tous les médias d'ailleurs va
de france prend la construction
d'information
votre avis sur les faits que news qu'est
ce que c'est est ce que c'est une des
opérations de spin doctor de différents
états se menant une bataille de
l'information sur nos raisins les
feignants je pense moi ça c'est des gens
perdus qui essaient de s'inventer de
réalité ou devant de leur propre leur
propre souple non l'effet que je pense
que c'est
c'est un
sous-produit d'internet ça va avec comme
sous produit du journalisme waouh bah
non la limite je crois que c'est plus
lié à l'internet c'est d'ailleurs
le revers de la médaille tout le monde
peut s'exprimer sur internet ça c'est
super
maintenant c'est un certain s'il ya
toujours eu des rumeurs des choses et le
fait que une rumeur puisse être parce
que c'est la faute des journalistes
est ce qu'on dit aux journalistes de
tous bords doivent pas laisser le
terrain
libre à toutes les propagandes parce
qu'ils aient pas leur taf lui
connaissait pas la convention de munich
bah ouais
moi je pense vraiment que l'effet que
news
ccc liées à la possibilité qui est
donnée à tout à chacun de construire de
construire une info fausses
et ensuite si elle est populaire si elle
répond un désir de l'audience elle va se
répandre comme une traînée de poudre
comme une crème poudre dire le gora
fille fait ça en très drôle
mais on peut faire ça en très
paranoïaque ou en très bref on peut
s'appuyer sur une émotion est-ce que ce
pur geek fait du clic pita clic
c'est-à-dire des titres aguicheur ou des
nouvelles un peu guichen les titre
aguicheur on essaye avant on essaie
d'avoir effectivement des titres des
titres qui accroche mais en même temps
on fait attention à ce qui est ce que le
contenu de l'article
soit
corrobore corroborent ce titre
maintenant
maintenant chaque chaque chaque journal
fait fait dans l'est les
sujets un peu con aucune valeur
journalistique je sais pas les plus
belles femmes de footballeur
j'ai vu dans le monde un singe qui un
singe avoir des relations sexuelles avec
une antilope dans le monde voilà et ça
ça fait du clic nous ont fait pas trop
ça après on fait en fait là nous on fait
on fait un truc on fait un truc mais un
truc qui n'est pas qu'ils aient pas trop
repris par les autres journaux les ovnis
ouais voilà on fait plutôt dans les
martiens nous on fait plutôt dans les
médias au sujet des fondeurs que l'autre
voilà c'est à dire que les gens les
nouvelles con qu'on donne son
proviennent de chercheurs il ya des
médias il ya tout un tas de gens qui
bossent des astrophysiciens machin ils
bossent ils bossent cherche des signaux
extraterrestres et quand il faut une
découverte on en parle alors de là à
dire
de là à dire
enfin de là à dire qu'on fait du pit à
cliquer parce que on parle de la
possibilité d'une vie extra terrestre je
pense que d'un point de vue
journalistique c'est risqué de parler de
la possibilité d'un
d'une vie extraterrestre maintenant d'un
point de vue strictement
voilà l'info de vue strictement
statistiques la possibilité qu'on soit
les seuls sur la planète et tout ça
c'est des choses qui se discute mais qui
ne se discute pas dans la presse
mainstream parce que ça fait dingue si
d'une baguette mais je vous offre une
baguette magique ouais vous pouviez
changer toute la presse
vos trois premières mesures ce serait
quoi
bon apprendre la convention de munich
pour tous les journalistes je suis
d'accord non ça je la garde pour moi
d'accord bon les trois premiers
les trois premières se serait
imposé des stages aux
eaux au coeur des populations des stages
des stages stages pour déchiffrer
l'information non non non non ont des
stages pour pour être un peu en rapport
en rapport avec les en rapport avec les
gens à être plus proche des gens être
moins
sortir de cette espèce de classe
journalistique qui se comprend qu'ils
sentent en est qui qui se répètent les
uns les autres
voilà
non mais c'est très bien d'avoir des
rapports confraternel voir corporatiste
mais mais
mais là je pense que c'est allé un peu
loin je pense que c'est allé un peu loin
les journalistes s'écoute trop se font
trop confiance ils se re met pas assez
en question connaissez l'expression de
l'internet les journalistes sont reçus
ce matin complètement moi quand j'étais
au venezuela
une fois je vois débouler c'était il y
avait quoi il y avait c'était sur la
libération de betancourt où ce genre
enfin sait même pas où ce genre c'était
là dessus et je vois débouler les mecs
un mec d'europe 1 un mec d'rtl
qui le demandent un fixeur donc là je
leur donne un fixeur ne voulez pas deux
fixeur moi on va partager le même fixé
un accord et les mecs ils bossaient
ensemble ils faisaient les mêmes papiers
au même moment avec les mêmes sources
ils sont deux radios concurrentes
mais je ne sais j'aime pas ça
one on bat façon ça on pourra pas faire
mieux
ok voilà ils bossent ensemble bon ceci
l'usure
deuxième mesure
[Musique]
deuxième mesure faudrait
faudrait une agence de presse qu'ils
soient
qu'ils soient réellement indépendante
donc à défaut à défaut il faut des
agences de presse alternative mais
l'idéal ce serait une agence de presse
qu'il soit vraiment indépendante qui
soit libre des intérêts américains ou
anglais ou français ou russes et qui
puisse donner une
une vision une vision indépendante du
monde devrait quatrième pouvoir ouais
ouais troisième mesure et troisième
mesure
la méritocratie à l'intérieur de la
presse je dirais qu'il ya un mois j'ai
vu des gens monter des gens qui est peu
d steam à la base mais en tant que
personne et puis aussi parce que je les
trouvais pas fine ni qui vais monter par
part
comme on dit
il était tellement conformiste tellement
il sortait pas de la ligne qu'au fur et
à mesure au fur et à mesure il faisait
pas de conneries les autres qui étaient
un peu moins conformistes aux dames en
ping à l'as tu t'es planté mec t'as pas
été sur la lie et
plus étaient cons et les gens qui sont
conformistes et qu'ils le sont toutes
tout le long de leur carrière ils ont
moins de mal à faire carrière donc ils
montrent plus au plus vite et il se
retrouve on retrouve avec des gens de du
conformisme chez spoutnik
non non parce que je pense qu'on a une
une rédaction qui est très très très
variés j'ai jamais vu autant de variétés
au sein d'une rédaction il ya des gens
qui sont
ça va l'extrême gauche à l'extrême
droite moi c'est la première fois que je
cohabite
professionnellement avec des gens
d'extrême droite y'a pas de l'extrême
centre un peu long si si et de l'extrême
centre aussi
d'une extrême centre de la gauche la
gauche molle s'il appelle le comme tu
veux
il ya déjà de tous il ya vraiment de
tout et du coup chacun chacun pousse son
son son pion et les autres parviennent à
s'y intéresser est-ce que c'est
problématique dans une carrière de
journaliste d'avoir travaillé pour les
russes en france ma grave voilà c'est ma
sphère que moi - de moi moi moi j'ai un
autre métier donc je
je sais que je sais je souhaite pas
réintégré et intégrer une rédaction
après ça mais je sais que si je l'avais
souhaité s'arrêter impossible enfin dans
l'état actuel des choses c'est quoi
votre métier de producteur de films que
type de films documentaires d'accord
votre maison de prod c'est quoi
les films grain de sable je fais et
autres pigeons
voilà entre autres un je travaille pour
pour d'autres boîtes de prod mais mais
j'ai fait je fais de la preuve depuis
plusieurs années ça m'amuse beaucoup on
prend le temps je suis je suis auteur
également d'un documentaire en ce moment
qui s'appelle
l'avenir de nos origines sur la
préservation en 3d du patrimoine
archéologique irakien bon coin jeu non
mais c'est bien on peut enfin tu rends
moi j'adore ça bon et votre patron ça va
pas trop qui est gentil qui est pas
gentil je sais qu'il est d'usagé chez
les russes de taper sur son patron avant
un gobelet de gros blessure son patron
ben non moi je pense que c'est ça est ce
que vous savez les critiques en face à
face ouais ouais imaginez-vous ces mots
votre rédacteur en chef
c'est quoi la plus grosse critique que
vous ayez à me formulé
tu devrais être plus souvent présent à
l'antenne tu devrais faire plus
tu devrais
y là il engage un porte parole comme
merde ouais mais manquant quand il ya
des sujets charge directe sur les
élections en russie il avait fait un
papier hyper intéressant une analyse
poussée intelligente modéré où il y
avait il y avait vraiment il donnait y
donner
il donnait une belle leçon d'objectifs
de journalisme sur sur un sujet qui
était évidemment pas facile parce que
le russie unie le parti de partie de la
meilleure poutine était très en tête
dans l'est dans les intentions de vote
et dans les résultats et donc tu avais
toute la presse qui hurlait à la la
dictature et lui il avait là dessus un
discours hyper intéressant où il disait
mais attendez il ya à l'intérieur de
russie ni les mêmes différences que vous
entre la gauche molle gauche du ps et la
droite de l'ex ump
donc qu'elle agit là d un acteur trente
cinq ans il ya des enfants ouais le
bitoux en
banlieue on habite
je sais pas où il habite à paris
montjoie et l'habitat de paris ses
impôts en france ouais sa femme est
française bref françaises
et français quoi barret
et français où les russes et français et
russes
moi j'ai une ouïe les russes comme enfin
chez pas j'aurais tendance à dire un de
quelqu'un qui est né en algérie qui vit
en france depuis vingt ou trente ans
qu'il est français donc
ça peut se plaquer aussi sur lui voilà
bon couchettes ou des vous avez des
partenariats vous êtes connecté à
guillaume n'ont ni assez peu connectés a
eu
lieu pour le coup c'est très compliqué
de les avoir ouais on a appelé jusqu'à
moscou pour les avoir moi et vous les
élans général de
ce coût mais pas de rythme en battant
spoutnik ça va vite bon à la retouche
est tous d eux
est ce que ça me pose problème que ne
soit pas très transparent
bah moi je me sens pas je pose pas avec
eux quoi je bosse pas avec eux
jean ils ont ils ont leur façon de
bosser ils ont leur source ils ont enfin
ils sont plus de moyens que nous
et
ils font un boulot enfin je veux dire
ils sont pas un penseur et il avait des
mecs sur place quoiqu'en
kankankan la presse française faisait
des articles incendiaires à partir
d'interviews sur skype il avait des mecs
sur place qui sont ils ont aussi leur
vision du journalisme est bon et ils
vont franchement vous avez des questions
vous posez
ouais moi c'est le ba non enfin j'aurais
bien une discussion à voir parce que moi
le hacking qui m'a toujours m'a toujours
toujours fasciné je trouve ça génial de
pouvoir tous que ça permet maintenant
comment ça marche quelle importance et
d'avoir envie est-ce que les hackers
français sont puissants très way traits
du soudan wad après ce qui tourne c'est
20% des acteurs mondiaux du mois les
wingles et
20% des hackers les 20 meilleurs pour
servir de france ah ouais c'est la
classe
c'est donc comme vous comme question
maintenant du coup du coup pour qui ben
pour pour qu'ils vous bossez du kivu
finances est ce que vous êtes tous nous
on n'est pas financé on est tous
bénévoles ont fait ça pour
pas notre honneur mais pour que notre
communauté soit plus endurcis face à
vous les journalistes vous savez quand
vous déteste tous que vous soyez à
gauche à droite russes français et
américains
on a un regard qui est très très
critique sur votre corporation
vous feriez mieux ouais comment déjà où
vous vire tous voila vous fait tous
écrire 25 fois la charte de munich ouais
et ensuite on vous fait passer votre bac
à l'accord pourquoi le bac pourquoi le
terrain parce que quand on voit certains
journalistes écrire des papiers c'est
encore pire que nous savent pas que la
france est à puis après trianguler une
source aller voir ce qui se passe
faire l'amour à une technique qui
s'appellerait defender comment le fait
pas parce que vous faites ça d'autre
chose à ouais et puis on n'a pas
signé pour être journaliste y quatrième
pouvoir par contre quant aux autres
communautés viennent nous chercher en
disant voilà ma vie va mal parce que
l'information est de mauvaise qualité
on est obligé d'un petit peu
je sais pas se serrer les coudes avec
nos copains d'école des gens comme lui
d'autres trajectoires comprend et on a
un point de vue qui est très critique
sur les journalistes alors on les prend
pas de temps en temps on leur explique
un peu les choses en face notre
mécontentement et on leur montre qu'on
est capable de faire mieux qu eux qu'ils
arrêtent de faire les malins parce
qu'ils sont tout petits on est toujours
plus petit que certains nous aussi on
est plus petit que d'autres mais on a
décidé de faire ça pour en durcir notre
communauté et pour peut-être améliorer
les choses et moi on est censé faire un
petit peu ce que vous faites c'est à
dire apporter une information de bonne
qualité pour que les gens puissent avoir
de quoi prendre une décision en âme et
conscience
voilà en même temps en même temps sur
des sur des problématiques d'actualité
quelle décision en a enfin on and on
n'est plus et vous comme nous mais plus
spectateur spectateur n'est que capteurs
on a
dansé mobilisme de la puissance du
journalisme on a mis 1
il ne faut pas tomber dans le
misérabilisme de l'impuissance un
journaliste pour nous ça doit être
quelqu'un une tête brûlée qui va
chercher l'information quoique quoique
ça lui en coûte 1 que ça lui en coûte sa
carrière sa famille ses enfants sont
empreints sa carte de presse sa belle
bagnole et labels pp qu'il aime bien
sortir dans tous les vernissages qui va
traîner avec ses copains journalistes
surtout parisiens ont les voies légales
pour aller derrière question qu'on va
vous poser à vous laisser un conseil
pour les jeunes générations
c'est une question qui est commune à
toutes nos interviews
donc c'est une bouteille à la mer sur
internet
faut pas se contenter
faut pas se contenter d'une seule source
faux faux faux vraiment faire un gros
effort pour
se mettre à la place de à la place des
autres et surtout pas oublier que au
final il ya des gens derrière tout ça
derrière derrière ce qui se passe en
syrie il ya des gens qui croient à la
révolution il ya des gens qui croient au
djihad il ya des gens qui croient en
bachar
qu'il faut pas croire que
que parce que nous on considère
que bachar saddam hussein h1 sont des
tyrans il n'y a pas des gens au poutine
il n'y a pas des gens nombreux qui sont
derrière eux et que c'est pas parce que
tu chine a une popularité qui frôle les
80 % qu'il ya 80% de russes qui sont
cons
[Musique]
ils voyent aurel merci merci à vous
e